einen richtigen favoriten gibt es nicht
sicher vorne dabei sagt der ehemalige
finanzminister der durch seinen
rücktritt die krise mit ausgelöst hat
penny mordend ehemalige
verteidigungsministerin für die rechten
dürfte es lässt seine außenministerin
oder doch eine
überraschungskandidat in cannes die
beiden noch jungen schwarz sie könnte
den parteiestablishment durch während
jetzt wird ausgesiebt durch die
parlamentsfraktionen in mehreren
wahlgängen bis zum 21 die beiden
kandidaten mit der größten unterstützung
bleiben übrig kommen ins finale
das heißt sie stellen sich der
parteibasis in mehreren
regionalkonferenzen dann briefwahl und
am 5 september soll die nachfolge von
boris johnson verkündet werden
was allerdings fest steht es entscheidet
die basis die ist extrem eu skeptisch
und niemand egal wer gewinnt dürfte es
wagen den konfrontativen praxiskurs von
beuys johnson anzutasten